so when people like eating background I
guess when I graduated so I was at the
UCLA and political science and then
Harvard Law School so you don't have
room to yourself a group logo uh I mean
I don't consider sociology a
particularly expert field but God I
think I'm able to read a sociological
study there laughs there lots of fields
of study offices so I know a lot less
about welding than I do about sociology
well yeah they're not considered an
effort and go geology psychology Gender
Studies lesbian a theory many of the
things that you've brought tonight I
know a lot more about all those others
than lesbian answer as far as if you
want to take issue with the argument I
would urge you not to use the argument
from Authority which is somebody has a
PhD by the end they know what they're
talking about
that's a dumb Argentine any of these
topics or any field say I don't need to
I don't need a seven year degree in
sociology no bullet when I hear it
[Applause]
right cuz I'm here yeah giving it again
you're just making a argument some
authority I don't think slapping a PhD
from Ferris State next to your name
makes you an expert in all things in the
field and what you propose to speak okay
the fact is that either my arguments go
to my arguments bad citing to my
credentials is a really bad way of
making an argument it's like the it's
actually the equivalent of it's so funny
Pete when people do this it's the
equivalent to actually a religious
person saying citing to the Bible for an
argument I'm a very religious person
right I mean see this sciama cog and
religious person okay I never cite to
the Bible the reason I don't cite to the
Bible is because that's an argument from
Authority okay you may not believe the
authority to which I'm citing I don't
believe the authority to which your
sightings you're going to have to make
me an argument as to what I'm saying
that's wrong instead of just saying I
don't have the properly enumerated
degree from the institution of your
choice
I'm merely a name didn't gonna need
three million study any type of
education you know establish yourself as
a PC or doctor many programs allow me a
qualified opinion any talk my question
because I have read the studies and I
can have an opinion on them and that
your opinion in mind was just basic
but yes that was my
[Applause]